In this lesson, we'll use Microsoft's HealthVault, but
there are several widely used PHRs and
they mostly do the same things. You should already have a HealthVault account,
but we haven't yet explored it to see how it stores clinical data and
what it can do to help patients use that data, including sharing it with others.
So here's some of my health data. I manually input in HealthVault.
You can see key data such as allergies, conditions, and medications.
As shown here, users are aided in recording this data by smart lists that
appear as they type. More recently, as meaningful use has dictated
the export of at least standardized clinical summaries from the provider's EHR,
the burden on the patients to record all their data is largely alleviated since
the PHR can and should import these summaries from all providers caring for
the patients. To aid that, note that I now have a direct email address.